Hey look, Mom, I'm studying Yiddish.
So I can talk to Grandma.
[Klezmer music]
Good day, guys. This is just a quick video
to answer a question that I got.
And I decided to make it into a video
because I've had this question before
and maybe, it's something that
a lot of people are wondering.
The question is :
"Are Hebrew and Yiddish similar?"
Or "are Hebrew and Yiddish kind of the same language?"
The answer to that is "No".
They are different languages.
They are often confused with each other because
the Yiddish language is written in the Hebrew alphabet,
in the same way that Farsi or Urdu
are written in the Arabic alphabet,
or that German is written
in the Roman alphabet just like English is.
So someone who doesn't read that script might look
at it  and think that it's the same language.
But Hebrew and Yiddish are different.
Another reason they might be confused is
that they are both related to Jewish people.
But they're related to Jewish people
in different ways, so...
Hebrew is the old language of the Bible,
of the Old Testament,
of the Hebrew Bible - as they would call it -, the Torah.
And it's also been a literary language
of Jews throughout the centuries.
Often, for religious purposes or literary reasons,
they would write in Hebrew.
But it was just a literary language for a long time.
It died as a spoken language.
But Yiddish was spoken by Jews in Europe.
And it's... The language it's mostly related to is German.
It's kind of a medieval form of German.
But I understand that, to some extent, Yiddish speakers
can communicate with German speakers.
And they can understand each other.
Not fully, but to some extent.
So it's mostly related to German, but it's been influenced
by Hebrew in terms of vocabulary.
And also by Aramaic
and maybe some other languages too.
Because Hebrew and Aramaic were
Jewish literary languages.
So there is some Hebrew vocabulary in it,
but I think the pronunciation has kind of
been changed and more Germanized.
So it doesn't sound like Hebrew so much.
So Yiddish was influenced by Hebrew
to some extent though.
And also Modern Hebrew
was influenced by Yiddish because...
the original Zionists who came to Palestine,
to create a Jewish state,
they were Yiddish speakers, I think, Yiddish,
maybe Russian or whatever.
But their native language, Yiddish, maybe also Russian
and others influenced Modern Hebrew.
So people say that Modern Hebrew syntax and phonology
reflects the Yiddish language to some extent.
So Yiddish has influenced Modern Hebrew as well,
but basically, they're separate languages.
And you can't communicate with someone
who speaks the other.
It would be easier for a Yiddish speaker to communicate
with someone who speaks German, I think.
Alright, so... Hopefully that is helpful.
And just a quick whole answer to that question.
Aright, talk to you later...
[Klezmer music]